i accidentally became a meme and this is
that story
hi my name is michael mcgee and you may
know me from this meme
hi i'm amber i am the girl in the
background of the me
i'm matthew rizzo and i'm the guy who
took the picture this all started in
2013
me and my best friend matthew we've
known each other since fourth grade
everybody knew who they were they were
really funny but i hadn't ever like
talked to them until
our algebra class it was my junior year
their sophomore year
and i sat by them and then we just
became friends after that i don't think
we had any assigned seating i can't
really remember how we ended up sitting
next to each other but
we just did for the whole year michael
said he sat by me
because he had a crush on me uh yeah i
mean she
she's a cute girl so i definitely at one
point
was crushing on her it was in october of
2013.
it was a pretty normal day in algebra
two i mean the booty had me like trend
was going around twitter at the time so
it was like during that week so i'm like
scheming up a plan to try to be like yo
we got to get in on the hashtag we gotta
see if you can make some
money i want to say maybe sixth or
seventh graders when we all kind of
noticed that michael like
every time he would laugh or make some
type of strain that his veins would pop
me knowing michael can make his veins
bulge out i'm like
yo michael make your veins blow down
real quick and let me take a picture
and he's like all right cool i hold my
breath and you know i just
flex my neck and head if that makes
sense
so really you know because the veins are
getting cut off of their oxygen and
blood they kind of you know
bulge out more also you're kind of
killing brain cells with it because
you're cutting off
the oxygen flow to your brain so it's
not the smartest thing to do
he took it at 1204 and i saw him like
making the face and i was like what
what is he doing then i just snuck my
phone posted the picture
and then i just left it alone i went
back to what i was in and then i would
just see
throughout the day that i get a couple
likes a couple of retweets it was funny
everyone in the class like saw it and
they all laughed but it was nothing
as to what happened two months later
we're on christmas break in december
and i went to sleep one night you know
my phone on the charger
and i woke up and my phone was you know
really
scorching hot so i thought like my power
outlet like short-circuited or something
and then i look on my phone and it has
like the 20 plus notification
on your twitter icon and i saw that a
guy on reddit or editor
had taken matthew's tweet and like kind
of pick stitched it to their own
and it was you know when you're holding
it a fart next to your crush
and it just blew up like i had all these
people
tagging me in the photo like hey is this
you i had people like yo i can't believe
this is you blah blah blah
blah overnight i went from like 700
twitter followers to like 3 000
or something like that it's definitely
been a universal meme
you know it can be brought into any
topic that's i guess the beauty of the
picture you can like take it any way you
want
that's what really kept it going it was
funny to me to like read all the
comments
on like reddit and imager and all that
like there were quite a few that like
i'll never forget
when you're vegan you haven't told
anyone in five minutes or where you've
coughed three times and you're trying to
hold in another one because you don't
want people to think you have covet
personally me i might be biased but i
think it's a top five meme of all time
again that's just my opinion though i
definitely wish i would have taken it
more seriously
copyrighted uh maybe get a legal team
behind me
but you know some new light with the nft
community booming
i noticed that a lot of the other meme
people that were in these videos
actually minted and sold their memes as
nfts
the overly attached girlfriend elena she
went to northwest high school we were in
the same track we had the same teacher
you know i'm going to try and be like
them and get on the foundation app
and you know mint and publish the
original meme photo
get some money and as far with amber me
and amber were always just really cool
we still hang out to this day michael
and i have made jokes like before like
that we were gonna get like married and
have it be like a mean wedding
and like everybody that was a meme was
gonna be invited but we're just friends
and like
they'll say whatever they want on the
internet that's i guess the beauty of
the picture you can like take it any way
you want and this picture is probably
going to live forever so
there won't be a moment in your life you
will not see his face
[Music]
you